hey keith you know i did my first
toasted butter cartoon in the bathroom
wall mm-hmm it's still there
i know someone drew a dick and toast
mouth oh i was drunk okay i thought that
was good
i'm an artist it's important to preserve
a little mystery you're not mysterious
lenny kravitz
he's mysterious lenny kravitz batman
look you're on your way to the top
newspapers tv show movie deals
so you're keeping knight i am it's funny
i didn't think you'd be
oh happens all the time i just love your
work and what you say with that
why is it that as people of color are
always having to stand for something in
our work
just the cartoonist because the world's
a racist place and that's why i keep it
light
keep it light yeah keep it light
don't move the suspect in question six
foot tall but you got the wrong guy
copy that this isn't the suspect
i can't believe they did us like that
are you cool
over here man mr policeman did a number
didn't he yeah you could be his it's
just like having a superpower
uh what's really going on bro earlier i
got my ass beat by the police
now i'm seeing things houston we have a
problem
man you woke up let's pop bottles make
cupcakes
did you guys lighten my photo i look
like sammy sosa uh
am i too black for my own comics oh
trust me no one's gonna ever accuse you
of being too black i'm sorry what hmm
down here my brother that's right i'm a
talking trash can
this is all wrong i'll tell you what's
wrong those man bun
co-opting gentrifying devils so you have
about 30 minutes till they trap you in
the sunken place well it feels like i'm
already there
if you were me what would you do you let
this out so you have to deal with it
the good the bad and the ugly you know
what to do
this is that moment in the matrix do i
take the red pill
or the blue pill i've got both in my
room if you want to experiment
[Music]